wenn die mich rüde von der seite
ansprechen spreche ich sie auch wieder
von der seite an frauen in dem business
sind selten doch sie setzen sich langsam
durch
der wettbewerb ist hart der wettbewerb
ist glücklich über
20.000 mattews fahren auf sei ruby
straßen immer im kampf um die meisten
fahrgäste
ich liebe matthäus die nicht laut sind
da kann ich nicht nach der schule
erholen aber in den engen fahrzeugen
kommt es immer wieder zu übergriffen
es ist sehr unsicher und trat damit zu
fahren aber in der nacht ist es noch
viel unsicherer
nairobi vier millionen metropole eine
million pendler und pendlerinnen am tag
öffentlicher nahverkehr fehlanzeige hier
gibt es nur private matthus große und
kleine busse unverzichtbar für die
menschen in kenias hauptstadt
fast jeden morgen mit ihrem auto durch
nairobis worte ätna ist ein sogenannter
taut sie lockt fahrgäste
je mehr desto höher hier verdient
[Musik]
ich stehe jeden morgen sehr früh auf und
weiß am ende des tages gehe ich mit
etwas geld nach hause es ist nie nichts
es ist immer ein bisschen geld etwas
arbeitstag beginnt morgens um vier und
endet abends um 610 euro bekommt sie
dafür am tag hart verdientes geld für
die zweifache mutter beschimpfungen
gehören zu ihrem alltag
manchmal nennen sie mich prostituierte
oder sie sagen du solltest mal heiraten
manchmal spreche ich andere fahrgäste an
wir sind ja nicht alle gleich entspreche
ich dir an und sie sagen der ist hier
schon gestresst angekommen
geschichten wie diese kennt nomura von
weiblichen angestellten oder fahrgästen
die von männern beleidigt belästigt oder
sogar vergewaltigt wurden als vor jahren
die zahl der sexualisierten gewalttaten
stark zunahm postete sie den facebook
hashtag my dress my dress mein kleid
meine wahl und tausende folgt mir
es gibt immer jemanden der eine meinung
über den haag deine klamotten darüber
wer du bist manchmal versuchen sie es in
taschen dich an und pushen dich ins bad
um
naomi hat gelernt sich in den bussen
anders zu verhalten egal wie sie
angesprochen wird sie antwortet immer
folglich
sie lächelt wenn ihr auch nicht danach
zumute ist alles um eine angespannte
situation nicht eskalieren zu lassen
es wurden drei videos online gestellt in
denen frauen brutal missbraucht und
vergewaltigt wurden in den bussen bis
dahin glaube ich haben die leute das
verharmlost oder kann um das ausmaß des
missbrauchs nicht
geändert hat sich seitdem wenig selbst
jetzt in corona zeiten sind die busse
vollgestopft weil alternativlos für
männer ein leichtes spiel
solange es matthäus gibt gab es nie ein
politisches vorgehen gegen sexuelle
belästigung und ich denke wenn mehr
frauen den matiz arbeiten können wir
dieses geschäft verändern
frauen im mato business sind immer noch
die ausnahme
95 prozent der beschäftigten sind männer
sie bestimmen
doch es werden mehr frauen fahren die
busse managen oder sogar fahren frauen
wie tracy morgan
manager diesen bus dieser bus gehört
meinem vater und die arbeit ist ziemlich
schwer der wettbewerb ist heftig richtig
hart aber wir versuchen gerade dieses
matata auf zu finden um es noch besser
zu machen
mit auch gefilmten fahrzeugen kennt er
sich aus mohammed reza kurz noaa ist
kenias bekannteste auto sprayer und
beliebt mit knapp 30.000 instagram
verloren der 46 jährige fällt selbst
deutschen luxus er kann es sich leisten
not ist stolz auf seine graffitis
mich war das richtig super denn die
leute haben langsam langsam darüber
gesprochen ich war im fernsehen in den
nachrichten überall in den nachrichten
hey da ist ein graffiti typ der an
matthäus arbeitet und ich danke gott
dass jetzt jeder designer das macht was
ich begonnen habe
ein hinterhof irgendwo in kenias
hauptstadt kaum vorstellbar doch was
hier schlummert sind morath schätze
dutzende von auto karossen
ausgeschlachtet abgeschliffen scheinbar
nutzlos nicht für den fünffachen vater
dessen leben so sagt er sich eigentlich
nur um familie seine trainings und sein
kreatives
wissen sie in kenia das ist die kultur
der menschen wenn das motto nicht gut
designt ist keine gute musik hat und
wird es keine fahrgäste bekommen sie
können ein neues motto kaufen ist
einfach so belassen und die menschen
werden sie anschauen und auf das nächste
wagen das graffiti und musik hat deshalb
einfach mit
gerade stimmt moha diesen bus auf über
1,5 millionen kenia schilling fast
12.000 euro lässt sich der besitzer
seine graffitikünstler kosten dazu heißt
die weder an videos boxen anlagen led
leuchten in einem bis jetzt
heruntergekommenen bus in zwei wochen
soll der vom acker rollen dann kann die
party mit special effects auch hier
losgehen
ich hab mal ein matatu mit einer
vip-lounge gemacht zu der zeit waren
tablets was für reiche typen wir haben
die nie matos gebaut du zahlst ein
bisschen mehr um in der via viele und zu
setzen du hast tablet wifi und gratis
getränke während du in die stadt fährt
je ausgefallener umso besser dabei
geraten gerade aufgepumpte matthus gerne
in polizeikontrollen die meisten fahrer
wissen mit kiki logo einen kleinen
steinchen geht es gleich weiter auch
wenn offiziell natürlich die sicherheit
der fahrgäste an erster stelle steht und
das ist auch wahr über 430 menschen sind
im vergangenen jahr of nairobi straßen
gestorben
der most
die meisten unfälle passieren in diesem
nahverkehr die fahrzeuge transportieren
menschen ein kleiner fehler der kann
sofort große schäden verursachen oder
unfälle die sehr viele menschen
betreffen
nachdem vor jahren ständig matthus
geklaut wurden haben sich die eigentümer
neu in sogenannten sakkos organisiert so
behalten sie leicht die kontrolle
christopher moore ja ist verbandschef
der matur besitzer nairobis ihm gehören
selbst vier große busse und er weiß wo
in seinem geschäft das problem liegt
die größte herausforderung ist dass wir
mit menschen umgehen verschiedenen
charakteren jeder angestellte hat seine
eigene art und seinen weg das fahrzeug
zu managen was wir normalerweise tun wir
drängen sie sich gut zu benehmen gute
manieren zu haben und gastfreundlich zu
unseren kunden zu sein
den kurs rudi bauer customers
matatu abgeleitet aus dem suaheli steht
für drei münzen so viel musste man
früher für einen frack bezahlen
inzwischen sind die preise deutlich
gestiegen in kenia gibt es keinen
öffentlichen nahverkehr und die meisten
menschen haben kein auto wer hier von a
nach b kommen möchte muss sich aus gehen
und ist auf die mattews angewiesen
auch die elfjährige purity in ihrer
klasse ist sie die einzige die mit dem
bus nach hause fahren muss um 17 uhr
tritt sie die heimfahrt mit dem matratze
an 90 minuten die einfache fahrt
80 schilling hin 80 zurück manchmal auch
mehr ein euro 40 viel geld für ihre
familie die sich die schule kaum leisten
kann oft ist beauty erschöpft dass matt
hof für sie auch eine kleine auszeit ich
mag die mattews ohne musik denn er kann
ich einfach nur sitzen und meinen kopf
frei kriegen von der schule
die dunkelheit die in kenia so schnell
rein bricht der lange weg mit dem bus
für ihre mutter die vier töchter hat
sind das immer wieder angst momente
es gab so viele vorfälle zum beispiel
ist das fahrgeld mal zu krebs dann nimmt
der fahrer sie nicht mit sie sagen wenn
du zu wenig bargeld hast dann kommst du
eben nicht in meinen mathe
hausaufgaben machen teetrinken abendbrot
daneben noch die schuluniform waschen
purity stuck ist noch lange nicht vorbei
wenn es in nairobi nacht wird
und auf den straßenrändern feuer oder
kenianer sagen los gatos
sind viel mehr als nur ein
fortbewegungsmittel
sie sind lifestyle sich bewegenden
leinwände und vor allem
nichts ist schneller als die nacht der
rhythmus der sound das flirten in den
eng vertreiben
wir mögen die musik und es ist ziemlich
komfortabel
status mit graffities wir gucken nach
graffitis und guter musik und es sollte
schnell sein
je mehr bling bling frosch desto wilder
die fahrt daran glauben sie hier dabei
sind nairobi straßen meist so verstopft
dass es nur im schritttempo vorwärts
geht ganz egal hauptsache die musik ist
laut und die stimmung ist nice
und so geht die nacht in den tag etwa
ist wieder unterwegs mit ihrem auto auf
der jagd nach fahrgästen es ist ein
hartes geschäft schlecht bezahlt dazu
doch für sie ist es der schönste job der
welt mit dem auto unterwegs zu sein
durch nebenstraßen